françois hollande le président de la
république en déplacement à trappes ce
lundi pour présenter sa refondation de
l'école il a d'abord discuté avec des
enseignants du collège gagarine
il a d'ailleurs salué les outils
d'innovation mises en place comme
l'expérience de l'accueil des enfants de
l'école élémentaire avant leur rentrée
au collège ce que vous avez fait ici à
trappes
nous devons le faire partout où il est
possible d'engager cette politique
l'objectif c'est que les enfants sortant
du primaire accèdent au second degré
avec des connaissances suffisantes
c'est en effet une piste extrêmement
intéressante puisque les enseignants se
connaissent mieux partagent davantage la
la même culture professionnels
réfléchissent ensemble sur les
progressions pédagogie sur l'accueil des
élèves et je pense que c'est un des
éléments d'explication important des
résultats très très prometteur de
l'établissement le secret il est la
fopac et rupture entre premier degré
second degré et si le socle commun est
déjà bien installé à la sortie du cycle
3 et des écoles on pourra que mieux
accompagner les élèves vers le lycée
dans son discours le président a rappelé
que l'école était la grande priorité de
son mandat
plus de professeurs avec l'ouverture de
22 mille postes aux concours externes de
2013 dont 6000 en contrat d'avenir
le rétablissement de la formation
initiale pour les enseignants il a
également confirmé l' annonce faite
dimanche par vincent peillon il y aura
bien des cours de morale laïque dispensé
de l'école élémentaire à la terminale
on va avoir le définir dans la
commission qui va se mettre en place
mais c'est tout ce qui relève pas
seulement de l'instruction civique c'est
à dire heures connaître les lois le
fonctionnement démocratique mais en même
temps réfléchir sur le sens de la vie
sur la justice sur les devoirs à l'égard
de soi même et à l'égard des autres des
annonces jugées par les eaux
je pense que c'est bien de remettre des
enseignants dans les classes
ce que ça maintenant il en manque après
les suppressions et malgré les mille
enseignants supplémentaires à la rentrée
je crois que il ya treize mille
suppressions de postes
donc ça j'espère que ça va être une
évolution et je pense qu'il faut
généralement plus d'adultes dans les
collèges
mise à part les enseignants évidemment
mais tous les personnels de direction
des cpe les assistants d'éducation
les postes les postes des gens qui
partent qu'ils vont être remplacés c'est
assez génial la formation parce que
c'est vrai que ces jeunes qui arrivent
c'est vrai que les gènes ont besoin
d'une formation on débarque pas comme ça
ici comme ça la concertation concernant
l'école devrait prendre fin au mois
d'octobre pour la présentation devant
l'assemblée nationale d'une loi
d'orientation sur l'éducation d'ici à la
fin de l'année